[music playing]
INTERVIEWER 1: Would you
like to live on the moon?
WOMAN: Yes, I would.
INTERVIEWER 1: You would?
You'd like to be one of
the first people to go?
WOMAN: Yes.
MAN 1: We have one of the most
challenging assignments that
has ever been given
to modern man.
MAN 2: The United States'
man in space program
is at least eight months behind
that of the Soviet Union.
Now it is time to take
longer strides, time
for this nation to
take a clearly leading
role in space achievement.
MAN 3: It's there.
We'd be neglecting our
duties as people if we
didn't try to investigate it.
ASTRONAUT 1: Oh, god, look
at that picture over there.
There's the Earth coming up.
Wow, that's pretty.
INTERVIEWER 2: You well may
be the first man on the moon.
How do you personally
feel about it?
ASTRONAUT 2: Well, I
have the same desires
as all the astronauts.
We'd all like to make that trip.
COUNTDOWN ANNOUNCER:
4, 3, 2, 1--
[rockets firing]
Liftoff.
Roger, liftoff.
ANNOUNCER: [inaudible]
has cleared the tower,
and there she goes, on
her way to the moon.
GROUND CONTROLLER: Houston,
you are go for landing, over.
[inaudible]
NEWS ANNOUNCER: They
should be within five
miles of their landing point.
How's America looking, Bob?
NEWS ANNOUNCER:
They're going in.
ASTRONAUT 3: 2,000 feet,
picking up some dust.
Tranquility Base here.
The Eagle has landed.
GROUND CONTROLLER: We
copy you down, Eagle.
[cheering]
[static]
ASTRONAUT 4: Uh, Houston,
we've had a problem.
ASTRONAUT 5: We got
more than a problem.
GROUND CONTROLLER:
OK, stand by, 13.
We're looking at it.
ASTRONAUT 5: [inaudible]
MAN 3: It's a stepping
stone to deeper space.
NEWS ANNOUNCER: It is no
longer a dream, but a reality.
ASTRONAUT 6: Welcome
to the moon, Houston.
GENE CERNAN: We leave as we
came, with peace and hope
for all mankind.